germany's new foreign minister has used
her first day on the job to take a
diplomatic tour of europe annalina
berbach has been busy meeting some of
germany's most important partners in
paris
and brussels today the green party
minister says that she will put climate
issues first and that she will take a
tough stand against autocratic states
she's also already made it clear she
supports a stronger european union
a trip to paris for annalina bearbox
first full day as germany's new foreign
minister
in her inaugural speech alongside her
french counterpart she called for a
stronger common eu foreign policy and
spoke about the growing diplomatic
boycott of the winter olympics in china
i hold a big space in my heart for
athletes
we in the german government need to
decide how we deal with the games but
that must be in accordance with our
european friends
next stop brussels
there bearbox stressed the importance of
the eu for germany and called for europe
to stand together in the face of russia
and china
it's not just about the military but
also a question of diplomacy the rule of
law and a strong shared economy in the
eu
music to the ears of the eu's foreign
policy chief
and elena
congratulations
the ambition to strengthen the european
union external actions and to promote
european union values
and interests more assertively and it's
certainly very much needed and i welcome
afterwards
met with nato secretary general before
wrapping a hectic day speaking with u.s
climate envoy john kerry
and for morning i'm joined by brussels
correspondent jack parent jack it's good
to see you let's start with the end of
today berbach meeting the u.s climate
envoy john
kerry i dare say that this is truly an
example of two meetings of the minds
with these two
surely is it's a really big day for and
elena bearbox senior figures across the
european union but also
an establishment figure like uh like
john kerry in
brussels on the same day as her on her
the first pretty much full day of her
job to talk about climate change and
analyna bearbox throughout all her
meetings today has made it extremely
clear that obviously while she's foreign
minister as a green elected politician
part of her foreign policy is going to
be about dealing with the climate crisis
and there's no question that john
kerry's place as the special envoy from
the white house on this issue
that that is an important meeting for
her to have had and she also had
meetings today with the head of nato and
with the european union's foreign policy
chief what does this tell us about the
imprint that she hopes to make on the
european stage
well it's really interesting that she
came here and she had all of these very
senior meetings and specifically on
security and defense policy as well
which is obviously a big part of her job
as the foreign minister of germany i
think in the post-medical era these
questions surrounding
you know who would take over who would
uh continue
this sort of line of miracles government
and one thing that annalina bearbox has
been keen to do is to show continuity
she's obviously from a different party
that not everybody
here in brussels knows her too well but
she tried to say listen on the issues of
the of belarus and the stuff that's
going on at the border there we
still want to put pressure on the
government in minsk the troop built up
on ukraine's border by russia she
continued to say that to condemn that
and to say uh that nato and the european
union need to act together on those
issues and so i think she was there to
also show some continuity from the
previous government even though the
issues that all the sides and all the
sides will eventually have to discuss
uh it's quite new for her on her first
day
and we know jack what she's trying to
project but what about the people that
she was meeting today i mean do we know
how she was truly received
i think she was pretty warmly received
to be honest brent she was all smiles
warmly interacting with all of these uh
people that she was meeting from the
from the head of nato the foreign policy
chief and everybody else that she's met
the the french foreign minister as well
that she started her day out in paris
it's important to state that as foreign
minister one of the very key things is
personal relationships and they spend a
lot of time together she mentioned and
off the back of her meeting with joseph
beret the foreign policy chief that
she'll be seeing him in liverpool and
then back here to brussels
for a foreign affairs council they spend
a lot of time together they deal on
pretty tricky issues and it was clear
she was trying uh to put the best
version of herself across i think what's
interesting as well she's spoken a
couple of the press conferences in
english here in brussels which is
something that uh you know you sort of
matters in the eu spheres as well
sometimes so i think she's broadly been
well received all right dw's brussels
correspondent jack parrish with the
latest tonight jack thank you
it was also the first full day on the
job for germany's new chancellor olaf
schultz the coronavirus pandemic and the
fear of a war in ukraine mean there will
be no honeymoon for chancellor schultz
to settle in dw political correspondent
jared reed followed the new chancellor
today
germans have woken up to a new
chancellor and here in berlin olaf
schultz's first day in this big office
right here began with plenty of fresh
snow he's got a lot to do not only does
he have to take over all of the pressing
issues and crises that angela merkel was
dealing with up until now but he also
has to attend to all of the new
government formalities and handovers
that are still taking place
first up a trip to his old office the
powerful finance ministry schultz has
handed control of this over to junior
coalition partner the business friendly
free democrats and its leader christian
lintner olaf schultz says germany needs
to build up its reserves for the next
crisis with fiscally conservative
lintner now in charge of how money is
spent he could and probably will make
things rather tricky at times for the
chancellor's agenda
and so that's the mission for the time
being to make sure that we manage to
create the reserves to organize the
stability areas that we need so we can
act whenever we need to and at the same
time manage to shore up the future
that means managing climate change and
modernizing the country
and then it's straight back here to his
new office at the chancellery olaf
schultz is presenting himself on the
world stage in front of more than 100
countries he's representing germany at a
virtual so-called democracy summit that
the u.s is hosting
when it comes to relations with our
lives schultz's foreign minister analina
bierbach has already been laying some of
the groundwork she's been in brussels
and paris ahead of visits by her new
boss on friday
but for the new government all of that
really takes second place to the biggest
problem right now and that's of course
covert 19. the end of all of schultz's
first full day as chancellor has been
taken up by talks on this with the
leaders of germany's 16 states
whatever stricter measures are next will
be decided shortly the government wants
to break the current severe fourth wave
of the pandemic that's leaving hundreds
of people dead across germany each day
a big vaccine pushes on the cards as are
mandatory vaccines next year at least
for some professions